في النهاية ، يبدو أن مكالمة هاتفية مدتها 30 دقيقة
بين الرئيس الفرنسي
ماكرون وجو بايدن كانت مكالمة
وصفها البيت الأبيض بأنها ودية كانت كافية لنزع فتيل
الأزمة الدبلوماسية التي استمرت أسبوعًا بين
فرنسا
وسفير فرنسا الأمريكية في واشنطن
سيعود إلى  العاصمة الأسبوع المقبل
دخلت فرنسا في هذه المكالمة الهاتفية
بقائمة محددة بشكل غير عادي من المطالب
بإجراءات ملموسة لإعادة بناء الثقة
والاعتراف بشكل حاسم بأن الولايات المتحدة كان
بإمكانها وينبغي أن تتعامل مع الأمر برمته
بشكل أفضل
فيما يتعلق بإعادة بناء الثقة والخطوات الملموسة التي
سيلتقيها مكوي وبايدن
شخصيًا في أوروبا الشهر المقبل فيما يتعلق
بالحصول على آسف من الرئيس الأمريكي ،
اقتربت فرنسا على
الرغم من أن التناقض بين
النسختين الإنجليزية والفرنسية للبيان المشترك
يتحدث عن مجلدات
تتواصل بها اللغة الفرنسية تفيد
بأنه كان من الممكن تجنب الأزمة من خلال
التواصل الأفضل بين  حلفاء النسخة الإنجليزية
لا تذهب إلى هذا الحد وتقول
فقط أن الوضع يمكن أن يكون على ما هو عليه  لقد استفادت الشركة المصرية للاتصالات
من المشاورات المفتوحة ،
لكن الفرنسيين حصلوا على شيء في
الملعب من اعتذار من
أقوى رجل في العالم ، رئيس الولايات
المتحدة ، وهم يشيرون
إلى أنهم مستعدون للتحرك نحو
سيريل فانير سي إن إن باريس